Ah, okay. Können Sie das machen? Sehr gut, okay.
Guten Abend, mein Name ist Burat Untaj. Ich bin der Dienstarbeiterarzt hier und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir, ja.
Ich brauche erstmal ein paar persönliche Daten, dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Lisa Kraft.
Können Sie bitte Ihre vollen Nachnamen langsam buchstaben?
Ja, Lisa ist L-I-S-A. Ganz einfach, ein Frauenname, ne? Und Kraft K-R-A-F-T.
Frau Kraft, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 13.07.65.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,61.
Wie viel schwer sind Sie?
Wie viel ich wiege? Ja, also ich wiege so 97 Kilo.
97?
Ja.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie gehabt?
Ja, also ich habe schon seit Tagen richtig heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Das klopft und also auf beiden Seiten. Ich habe richtig so dröhnen, als ob ich zu viel getrunken habe.
Oder so richtig heftige Kopfschmerzen. Hat plötzlich angefangen.
Und ja, ich habe dann zweimal Ibuprofen genommen.
Dann ist es auch ein bisschen besser geworden. Dann konnte ich auch schlafen in der Nacht.
Aber was jetzt so komisch ist, ich habe mit einmal so Sehstörungen.
Ich kann nicht richtig gucken. Das flimmert so vor meinen Augen.
Ich kann gar nicht richtig sehen.
Und das hat mir jetzt richtig Angst gemacht.
Und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt entschieden, ich komme jetzt doch mal.
Also mein Mann hat mich halt gebracht, ne?
Der hat mich dann hier in die Klinik gefahren.
Und weil ich gedacht habe, das ist jetzt komisch, dass ich nicht richtig mehr gucken kann.
Und das ist so plötzlich gekommen, ne?
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, also dass ich nicht so gut gucken kann, das ist seit heute Vormittag.
Vormittag.
Und Sie haben gesagt, diese Beschwerden sind plötzlich aufgezählt.
Ja, also die Kopfschmerzen waren mit einmal da.
Und diese Sehstörungen, das ist jetzt irgendwie neu dazu gekommen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, beidseitige Kopfschmerzen.
Ja.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, hier so auf beiden, hier so so.
Können Sie diese Beschwerden, diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, es klopft und dröhnt.
Also es sind so klopfende, ja, als ob da einer mit einem Hammer drin ist.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkater von 1 bis 10?
Irgendwie so, ja, so irgendwie so in der Mitte.
Also die sind nicht unerträglich, aber sie sind unangenehm, ja.
Vielleicht 6 oder 5?
Vielleicht so bei 5, ja.
Können Sie bis zum Ende ausmachen?
Ja, natürlich, die Kopfschmerzen habe ich ja schon seit ein paar Tagen.
Das ist nicht so wild, aber weil es halt nicht aufhört, deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal herkommen.
Haben Sie für einiges Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, also ich habe schon immer mal wieder Kopfschmerzen, schon, aber dieses mit den Sehstörungen, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Also kann ich nicht sagen, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Klar ist es draußen warm, es ist komisches Wetter, aber ob das jetzt der Auslöser ist, glaube ich nicht.
Ich kann das eigentlich nicht festhalten.
Außer Ibuprofen, was lindert oder versteckt für Sie mit diesen Schmerzen?
Ja, also ganz gut geht es, wenn ich so ein bisschen im Dunkeln liege, dann habe ich das Gefühl, oder überhaupt wenn ich liege und ruhig bin.
Und ich mochte jetzt heute nicht in die Sonne gehen oder so, das wäre nichts gewesen.
Leiden Sie Liedanfänglichkeit?
Bitte?
Leiden Sie unter Lichtanfänglichkeit?
Ja, das eigentlich nicht, aber ich wäre jetzt nicht in die Hitze rausgegangen, sage ich so.
Das wäre mir glaube ich unangenehm gewesen.
Und jetzt diese Geschichte mit den Augen, da weiß ich gar nicht.
Da würde ich vielleicht auch eher nicht ins Helle gehen, ja.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen?
Habe ich ja gesagt, ich habe so Flimmern vor den Augen.
Ja, aber außer Flimmern, noch Erdrehen oder Verschwommen Sehen?
Ne, verschwommen nicht, es ist ja verschwommen.
Das Bild wackelt halt so, wie ein altes Fernsehbild.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder müssten Sie Erbrüchen?
Nein, nein, nein, so schlimm sind die Kopfschmerzen nicht.
Haben Sie Tapasgefühl oder Kribbel?
Wer soll kribbeln? Hier kribbelt nichts bei mir, nein.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, das sind Kopfschmerzen, die strahlen irgendwo hinaus.
Nur Kopfschmerzen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Wo zufügen?
Außer Kopfschmerzen und Flimmern.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ne, aber das langt mir völlig.
Also das macht mir ja schon Sorgen, dass ich jetzt seit Tagen Kopfschmerzen habe,
aber mit einmal nicht mehr richtig gucken kann.
Haben Sie Müdigkeit?
Müde bin ich ja nicht besonders.
Okay. Jetzt würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem Allgemeinstand stellen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Haben Sie Schüttelvorsuchte oder Nachschweiß?
Ne, also mit dem Schwitzen bin ich durch, das Thema habe ich nicht mehr.
Vermeinteschwitzen oder ganz normal?
Früher in den Wechseljahren hatte ich das ja, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Leider nicht abgenommen, ja.
Wie viel Kilo?
Ne, leider nicht abgenommen sage ich. Ich will ja schon ein bisschen viel für meine Größe.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, also beim Wasserlassen ist schon so, dass ich nachts einmal wenigstens auf die Toilette muss.
Seit wann?
Seit ein paar Jahren. Ja, zwei, drei, drei, vier Jahre.
Ist auch nicht jede Nacht, aber ziemlich häufig.
Entschuldigung, was genau ist dieses Problem beim Stuhlgang?
Beim Stuhlgang habe ich gar keine Probleme. Ich nur beim Wasserlassen, dass ich nachts raus muss.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Also wie gesagt einmal nachts auf die Toilette, aber danach schlafe ich sofort weiter.
Ich bin eigentlich immer ziemlich müde.
Trinken Sie genug? Ich meinte Wasser.
Ich bemühe mich. Ob ich das wirklich immer schaffe, bei so warmem Wetter zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich bemühe mich eigentlich schon, dass ich so auf gut zwei Liter komme am Tag.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind in der Männerpause.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauarzt regelmäßig?
Meinen Frauenarzt? Ja, da gehe ich immer zu dieser Krebsvorsorge hin.
Bitte nochmal.
Da gehe ich regelmäßig einmal im Jahr zur Krebsvorsorge hin.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Naja, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Da kriege ich aber Tabletten.
Wobei der ist jetzt auch, ich messe da hin und wieder mal zu Hause.
Als ich zu Kopfschmerzen hatte, habe ich auch gemessen.
Da war der auch ziemlich hoch, aber vielleicht auch, weil ich irgendwie ein bisschen erschrocken war.
Gestern war der bei 140 zu 80 und heute war er dann bei 180 zu 90.
Aber ich nehme da immer Ramipril und dann nehme ich halt eine Tablette.
Wie ist da die Dosis?
Ramipril 5 ist das, glaube ich.
Einmal täglich?
Nehme ich eine Tablette, ja.
Dann habe ich irgendwie schon seit 10 Jahren diesen Altersdiabetes.
Da nehme ich regelmäßig mit Formin und mein Hausarzt kontrolliert das eigentlich auch.
Aber jetzt ist er im Urlaub und ich habe jetzt auch länger nicht kontrolliert.
Ich habe auch keine Teststreifen mehr und da habe ich jetzt länger nicht kontrolliert.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal gemessen?
Oh, das ist bestimmt schon ein Monat her.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Ne, sonst, ja ich habe vor 10 Jahren mal die Gallenblase rausbekommen.
Seit wann genau?
Das ist 10 Jahre her.
10 Jahre. Und seit wann leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit?
Die Zuckerkrankheit hat man vor 10 Jahren festgestellt und mit dem Bluthochdruck, das ist so 5 Jahre her.
Neben den genannten Medikamenten nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Das mit Formin nehme ich regelmäßig und Ramipril.
Und bei Bedarf, wenn ich mal heftige Schmerzen habe irgendwo, dann nehme ich Ibup.
Wissen Sie die Dosierung?
850.
850. Einmal täglich?
Einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Zwei. Und Ramipril, Sie haben einmal gesagt, oder?
Genau.
Morgen oder abends?
Morgen nehme ich die.
Ibuprofen, kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Von wem?
Kennen Sie die Dosierung Ibuprofen?
Oh, das sind glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht. Ich glaube es sind 600er.
600er.
Aber die nehme ich auch wirklich nicht ständig. Also wie gesagt nur wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe oder wenn irgendwas ist.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwas?
Ja, also ich weiß, dass ich kein Penicillin nehmen darf.
Das habe ich mal bekommen und da habe ich so einen ganz heftigen Ausschlag von bekommen. Also das darf ich nicht nehmen. Aber sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Haben Sie Unversorglichkeit?
Nee, ich sage es doch nicht. Sonst habe ich nichts.
Ich würde jetzt gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten stellen.
Rachen Sie vor Kraft?
Nee, ich bin nicht rocheren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also nicht regelmäßig. Aber hin und wieder am Wochenende trinke ich schon gerne mal ein Glas oder ja bei einem Fest.
Was weiß ich, Weihnachten oder wenn man sich mit Leuten, mit der Familie trifft oder so.
Dann trinke ich auch mal ein Gläschen mit, aber nicht viel.
Was trinken Sie?
Ich trinke gerne mal Wein. Wenn es so heiß ist im Sommer wie jetzt, dann trinke ich auch gerne mal ein Bier.
Und vielleicht gibt es mal so ein kleines Likörchen oder so was zum guten Kaffee dazu oder so.
Aber wie gesagt, nicht Tag für Tag.
Haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, nein, nein. Damit habe ich nie etwas zu tun gehabt.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch vor Kraft?
Mein Vater ist sehr früh gestorben und meine Mutter, naja gut, die wäre jetzt natürlich auch schon über 90.
Also die ist mit 88 oder so gestorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ich denke, meine Mutter ist an Altersschwäche gestorben.
Irgendwann ist halt, da hat man nicht weiter nachgefragt.
Die hatte aber die letzten Jahre immer Probleme mit ihren Knochen der Taten, immer ihre Gelenke weh.
Und die hatte so, ja, dass sie dann dachte, ja, jetzt ist alles wieder beschwollen und so.
Das war das Einzige, aber sonst war die eigentlich so ganz gesund.
Und mein Vater ist ganz früh gestorben.
Der hatte Lungenkrebs.
Der hat natürlich auch eine doofe Arbeit gehabt. Der hat unter Tage im Bergwerk gearbeitet.
Und der hat natürlich immer viel Staub eingeatmet. Anfang 40 ist der gewesen, da ist er schon gestorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Schwestern, ja. Ich hatte zwei Schwestern.
Und die älteste, die ist wirklich auch nicht alt geworden, die hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Aber die jüngste ist gesund.
Bitte?
Die jüngste Schwester ist gesund.
So viel ich weiß, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind mit Ihrem Mann gekommen.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon aus dem Haus.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe zwei große Töchter.
Sind sie gesund?
Ja, also gesund sind die schon grundsätzlich. Also die eine, die ist aber auch sehr übergewichtig.
Also die wiegt noch mehr als ich. Und ja, das macht ihr natürlich zu schaffen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich arbeite immer noch Teilzeit als Buchhalterin.
Sehen Sie damit zu Fähre?
Ja, ich habe natürlich nicht viel Ehrgeiz, aber eigentlich macht mir die Arbeit Spaß.
Ich gehe gerne mit Zahlen um und habe es gerne ordentlich. Ja, das macht mir eigentlich viel Spaß, die Arbeit.
Okay. Wir sind doch gleich fertig, Frau Kraft. Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich wüsste jetzt natürlich schon gerne, woher diese Kopfschmerzen kommen und auch was es mit den Augen auf sich hat.
Und auch was man dagegen tun kann natürlich.
Bisher haben wir nur Anamnesengespräche durchgeführt, aber ich vermute bei Ihnen einen Migraine-Attack.
Aber wir sollen ganz systematisch vorgehen.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und Ihre Blutdruck kontrollieren.
Dann Blut abnehmen. Danach besprechen wir nächste Schritte.
Okay, das klingt vernünftig.
Warten Sie bitte im Untersuchungszimmer.
Okay, möchte jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen? Niemand möchte etwas von mir wissen. Na ja, gut.
Ja, ich kann eine Frage stellen.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie eine Sichthörung haben.
Also ja, ich könnte auch verpasst haben.
Aber ist es besser, wenn Sie ein Auge schließen?
Oh, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, okay.
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen, aber ich nehme es nicht an.
Das muss ich neugierig fragen. Sind Sie Augenarzt?
Nein, nein, ich bin allgemein Arzt. Also ich bin kein Parat.
Aber ich möchte ja auf Neurologie spezialisieren.
Ah, okay. Ja, jetzt verstehe ich. Okay, danke.
Noch eine andere Frage von jemand anderem oder auch noch von Ihnen?
Ja, noch eine Frage.
Hatten Sie früher eine Blutgerinnungserkrankung oder etwas so?
Eine Blutgerinnungserkrankung? Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Also das wäre ja bei der Gallenblasenoperation, wäre das ja aufgefallen, wenn ich eine Gerinnungserkrankung hätte.
Nee, aber da habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay, verstanden. Danke.
Gut. Jetzt weiß ich auch, wohin Sie denken.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Wir können anfangen.
Ja, gut.
Guten Abend Frau Oberärztin. Ich habe eine neue Patientin. Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Es handelt sich um Frau Lisa Kraft. Sie ist 61 Jahre alt, 1,61 Meter groß und 97 Kilo schwer.
Sie kommt zu uns wegen seit Vormittag bestehender beiseitig klopfender Kopfschmerzen.
Sie klagte über Photopsie.
Diese Beschwerden sind plötzlich aufgetreten. Sie hat zweimal Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber nicht geholfen.
Diese Beschwerden sind erstmalig aufgetreten.
In der Vorgeschichte gab es nicht Dürre.
Sie leidet an arteriöle Hypertonie und Diabetes Meltos Typ 2.
Vor ungefähr 10 Jahren wurde Kalumblasenentfernung vorgenommen.
Vor ungefähr 10 Jahren wurde Kalumblasenentfernung.
Sie leidet an alleriöle Hypertonie und Diabetes Meltos Typ 2.
In der Familienanalyse sind beide Eltern gestorben.
Der Vater der Patienten ist an Lungenkarzinom gestorben und die Mutter der Patienten ist in alter Schwäche gestorben.
Sie hat zwei Schwestern, eine von ihnen hat einen Myokadinfarkt. Sie ist verheiratet, hat zwei Kinder, eine von ihnen leidet unter Adipositas.
Sie arbeitet Zeitzeit als Buchhandtellerin. Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten Migrenanfälle.
Und differenzielle Diagnostik kommen auch spannende Kopfschmerzen und vielleicht Entgleisungsblutdruck.
Wer könnte noch entgleisen außer dem Blutdruck?
Sie hat manchmal kontrolliert und das erste Mal war es ein bisschen am Grenz.
Über der Grenze oder an der Grenze? Über der Grenze.
Gut, aber der Blutdruck könnte entgleist sein, das muss man jetzt gucken. Aber wer könnte uns auch noch Schwierigkeiten machen?
Was könnte noch Schwierigkeiten machen?
Meinen Sie bei der Blutdruck zurück?
Nee, von den Nebenerkrankungen oder von den Vorerkrankungen.
Diabetes? Ja, der könnte auch entgleisen. Ja, vielleicht.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit Ihrer Patientin?
Zuerst würde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie dabei besonders?
Zunächst muss ich Vitalparameter kontrollieren und Blutzucker auch. Insbesondere Blutdruck. Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Und was lassen Sie alles für Werte bestimmen?
Im Labor werde ich Blutbild, CRP, BSG kontrollieren, überprüfen und Blutzucker auch.
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
Und was machen Sie denn, wenn Sie die Patientin körperlich untersuchen? Wo legen Sie Ihren Fokus? Was prüfen Sie im Einzelnen?
Bei dieser Patientin ist es wichtig neurologische Untersuchung.
Ich achte darauf, ob es Asymethy-Tarpeidgefühl gibt.
Worauf achten Sie noch?
Nackensteifigkeit. Zum Beispiel, ja.
Und Extremitäten, Kraftlosigkeit, Tarpeidgefühl.
Ja, ja. Gut.
Was für Untersuchungen würden Sie noch anstellen? Außer körperlicher Untersuchungen und Laborwerten?
Gegebenenfalls können wir MRT veranlassen.
Von was?
Um eine Gerüntume auszuschließen.
Ah, ja. Okay. Hätten wir noch eine Differenzialdiagnose. Ja, okay.
Also wenn wir mit dem anderen Kram nicht weiterkommen. Ja, gut.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, fangen Sie mal an mit den Untersuchungen bei der Patientin.
Würden Sie sonst noch irgendwie ein anderes Bild geben, das Verfahren machen wollen oder?
Erstmal nicht, ne?
Gut, okay.
Ja, lassen Sie uns zur Besprechung kommen. Sie waren jetzt im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch sehr knapp.
Da haben Sie längst nicht alles gesagt, was Sie die Patientin gefragt haben.
Und zum Beispiel, Sie haben die Patientin ja gefragt, ob sie Fieber hat, ob sie Herzrasen hat.
Das hat sie ja alles verneint, klar. Aber das muss man ja auch im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch dann erwähnen und sagen.
Die Frage nach wurde verneint. Ich meine, Sie haben auch sich nicht geäußert über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten,
Alkohol, Nikotinkonsum, Drogenkonsum haben Sie nicht erwähnt.
Was mir beim Fragestellen aufgefallen ist, Sie haben gefragt, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala einordnen?
Und da war die ja so ein bisschen ratlos. Sie müssen schon dazusagen, von wo bis wo geht die Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10.
Und keine Schmerzen ist 0 und 10 ist das Schlimmste.
Dieser blöde Schmerz, der kommt immer, ja, es ist ein bisschen eintönig. Ich weiß ja, dass der kommt.
Mir ist diese Schmerzskala ja auch klar. Und Ihren Prüfern ist die natürlich eigentlich auch klar.
Aber Sie müssen das dazusagen. Also der Patient geht mit dieser numerischen Schmerzskala nicht so alltäglich um,
wie Sie als anamneseerhebender Arzt. Und auf der anderen Seite, ich muss immer so ein bisschen grinsen,
wenn wir hier unsere Anamnese-Gespräche machen, gehen Sie heute mal in eine deutsche Arztpraxis mit irgendwelchen Beschwerden.
Da fragt kein Mensch irgendwas. Da werden Sie nicht gefragt.
Ja, wird vielleicht gefragt, welche Medikamente Sie nehmen. Aber die Ärzte wollen überhaupt nichts wissen von einem.
Und da denke ich immer, ja, wir sind hier auf einem schönen Stern unterwegs mit unseren Simulationen.
Der Realität entspricht, dass wir nicht so hundertprozentig.
Und mich hat zum Beispiel auch noch nie, glaube ich, irgendein Arzt gefragt nach Familienanamnese.
Echt nicht. Obwohl das ja eigentlich wirklich schon eine ausgeprägte Relevanz hat.
Mich hat es noch keiner gefragt, woran meine Eltern gestorben sind. Echt nicht.
Sehr gut. Ja, hier in unseren Situationen kommt es vor.
Da haben Sie, das haben Sie wiedergegeben im Dings.
Sie waren sehr knapp bei der Beschreibung der Symptomatik. Und da waren Sie auch nicht ganz exakt.
Denn Sie haben gesagt, Sie hat seit dem Vormittag Kopfschmerzen und Sehstörungen.
Das stimmt nicht ganz. Sie hat ja gesagt, die Kopfschmerzen hat sie seit drei Tagen.
Und hat deswegen auch die Tabletten genommen.
Und eigentlich ist sie jetzt gekommen, weil die Kopfschmerzen nicht besser werden.
Und weil sie zusätzlich diese Sehstörungen bekommen hat. Die hat sie erst heute. Die hat sie erst seit heute vormittag.
Das ist also schon unterschiedlich.
Das war diese Geschichte. Dann, ja genau.
Sie haben die Patientin gefragt, haben Sie Taubheit oder Kribbeln?
Ja, mal ganz ehrlich. Taubheit kann ich nicht gut hören.
Also müssen Sie schon fragen, wo? Spüren Sie ein Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbeln in Armen oder Beinen?
Oder in einer Gesichtshälfte oder so?
Gut.
Welche Punkte sprechen denn nach Ihrer Einschätzung für die Migräne, für Ihre Hauptdiagnose?
Bitte?
Ah, okay. Was spricht dagegen?
Schmerzintensität.
Ja, die ist stärker, ne?
Verlängerung der Geräusche.
Und genau. Oh ja, genau.
Und sie hat ganz klar gesagt, beidseitig.
Die klassische Migräne ist halbseitig mit Symptomatik auf der Gegenseite.
Das ist ja so krass. Das ist die einzige Erkrankung oder eine der ganz wenigen,
wo ich persönliche Erfahrungen habe.
Sonst bin ich immer in ganz großen Nöten, wenn ich Schmerzqualitäten beschreiben soll.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn man Gallensteine oder Nierenkuliken oder sonst irgendwas hat.
Aber Migräne kenne ich, ja.
Und es ist sehr krass, da ist die Lichtempfindlichkeit ganz extrem.
Und da kommt aber auch eine Geräuscheempfindlichkeit dazu.
Aber sehr massiv ist diese Halbseitigkeit und dann eben die Ausfälle auf der Gegenseite.
Das ist schon richtig.
Und Sie haben dann ja gesagt, bei den Untersuchungen, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung gucken Sie auch auf Nackensteifigkeit.
Was wäre denn da, dahinter die Diagnose?
Meningitis.
Ja, genau. Und das wäre sicherlich auch noch so ein Ding.
Aber die Halbseitigkeit ist halt nicht gegeben.
Und auch drei Tage eine Migräneattacke ohne Übelkeit und so. Wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Was Sie nicht erwähnt haben im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch ist zum Beispiel Deneukdorie.
Und ich glaube, Sie haben auch die Allergie nicht erwähnt, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Nein, nein, ich habe gesagt, Benesilien-Allergie mit Erysathen.
Ah, ja, okay. Aber nicht, wie Sie sich auch sagen.
Gut, okay.
Dann, also am Anfang habe ich ordentlich Schwierigkeiten gehabt, die gut zu verstehen.
Das hat sich dann im Laufe der Zeit gebessert.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch eigentlich sehr souverän formulieren.
Wie lange lernen Sie schon Deutsch?
Erstes halbes Jahr?
Intensiv seit sechs Monaten.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Seit drei Jahren ungefähr.
Ah, okay. Nee, aber eigentlich machen Sie ganz wenig Fehler.
Manchmal ist es eben von der Satzmelodie, dass man sie nicht so gut versteht.
Und der Klassiker.
Zuerst ich werde Sie untersuchen.
Ja, also das Verb steht an zweiter Stelle.
Meine heilige Kuh, ja, das kommt immer wieder.
Zuerst werde ich Sie untersuchen.
Oder ich werde Sie zuerst untersuchen.
Aber nicht zuerst, ich werde.
Genau, der kam.
Und das waren aber auch die Hauptpunkte, die ich hatte.
Also das mit den drei Tagen.
Oder seit dem Vormittag.
Also wie gesagt die Sehstörungen seit dem Vormittag.
Aber die kommen zu den Kopfschmerzen von drei Tagen dazu.
Die Patientin hat Ihnen eigentlich einen Hinweis gegeben für die richtige Diagnose.
Sie hat nämlich gesagt, sie war schon länger nicht bei der Kontrolle zum Diabetes.
Und Ihre Teststreifen sind ausgegangen.
Also diese Urinenteststreifen.
Die kann sich also selber nicht testen.
Und tatsächlich ist der Fall, dass Sie die Diagnose nicht testen.
Und tatsächlich ist der Fall ein Entgleis der Diabetes.
Aber als Differentialdiagnose ist die Entgleis der Hypertonie.
Oder eben die Migräne ist hier erwähnt.
Dann ist tatsächlich auch der Gehirntumor erwähnt gewesen.
Und eine Tier.
Ja, wobei sie hat ja ausdrücklich gesagt keine Herzbeschwerden.
Also Tier ist ja hier Dingens.
Die chemische Attacke.
Ja, da hätte sie aber mehr neurologische Ausfälle eigentlich.
Also das ist nicht so richtig wahrscheinlich.
Aber man muss sicherlich in die Richtung einmal checken.
Welche neurologischen Prüfungen würden Sie denn machen bei so einer Patientin?
Außer MRT?
Ja, also welche neurologischen. Also bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Kraniaren kontrollieren.
Ja.
Und vielleicht auch wenn Sie gerade bei der Migräne wären, würde man Seitenvergleich machen.
Sensibilität und Motorik vielleicht auch gucken.
Und vielleicht auch Pupillenreflexe.
Wäre vielleicht auch interessant.
Also geben wir noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Mir fällt noch ein, dass wir zwei Sachen nicht im Fragenkatalog hatten.
Sie hatten keine Frage nach dem Impfstatus.
Und Sie hatten keine Frage nach der Reiseanamnese.
Ja, ich dachte Sie sind unausfällig.
Was?
Ich dachte Sie sind nicht wichtig.
Ach so, ja. Also da bin ich auch immer sehr unsicher.
Wie gesagt, im medizinischen Alltag in einer deutschen Klinik wird kein Mensch Sie nach der Reiseanamnese fragen.
Wenn Sie nicht gerade mit irgendwelchen komischen Ausschlägen, die hier kein Mensch kennt,
oder mit so einer typischen Malaria Symptomatik kommen, fragt keiner, ob Sie eine Reise gemacht haben.
Wenn Sie mit Kopfschmerzen kommen, fragt keiner.
Insofern haben Sie natürlich recht.
Aber in der Prüfungssituation würde ich es tatsächlich der Vollständigkeit halber doch noch fragen.
Und der Impfstatus?
Ja, wir sind ja inzwischen schon so ein bisschen wieder beruhigt, was Covid angeht.
Wobei das Ding ja immer noch nicht vom Tisch ist.
Wir haben immer noch Covid-Erkrankungen und Neuinfektionen.
Und gerade für alte Leute ist ja dieser ganze Strauß an zusätzlichen Impfungen gar nicht so uninteressant.
Was Grippeimpfung angeht, was diese ganzen, was ist denn das, Gürtelrose und sowas.
Da kann man ja eben heutzutage auch noch wieder viel machen, auch im Alter, dass man da das Risiko senkt.
Gut, ja, also wie gesagt, Sie waren mit Ihren Differentialdiagnosen sehr nah an der echten Diagnose,
an dem tatsächlichen Krankheitsbild.
Spätestens hätte sich das natürlich gezeigt in dem Augenblick, wo Sie die Blutwerte sehen.
Wenn Sie Blutzucker Hb1c sehen, dann wissen Sie, ja, das ist es.
Und vielleicht würde auch schon der Teststreifen einfach im Urin helfen, um zu sehen, ups, da ist was.
Ja, gut.
Ich habe mich geirrt wegen Phlema-Photopse.
Nochmal bitte?
Ich habe mich geirrt wegen Photopse.
Ja, ja, dieses Augenflimmern, das ist ja auch so ein Diabetes, bei extremen hohen Blutzuckerwerten kommt es ja dazu.
Und das ist eigentlich so das Leitsymptom, ja, und das führt zur Migräne hin, gebe ich zu.
Aber das hätte man ja auch noch ein bisschen verifizieren können und nachfragen.
Wenn man das über die Migräne weiß, dann hätte ich tatsächlich noch mal intensiver nachgefragt nach Übelkeit und Lichtempfindlichkeit und Geräuschemfindlichkeit.
Weil das ja eigentlich sehr, sehr klassisch ist bei Migräne.
Und vielleicht kommt auch noch dazu, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob man in dem Alter dann nochmal neu Migräne bekommen kann.
Vielleicht kann man das immer bekommen.
Aber eigentlich, dass das dann das allererste Mal auftritt in dem Alter, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Aber na gut, den Zucker hat sie halt und ist bekannt.
Und sie hat natürlich massiv Risikofaktoren durch ihr Übergewicht.
Dadurch liegt das also relativ nahe mit dem Blutzucker, was nicht ist.
Gut, das ist ein Düsseldorfer Fall, fällt mir ein.
Und ja, ich habe ihnen ein paar Tipps gegeben, wo sie intensiver nachhaken müssen und wo sie tatsächlich ein bisschen präziser fragen müssen.
Dieses Taupal kribbeln, da hat die ja nur sie blöd angeguckt.
Was wollen sie von mir? Wer kribbelt?
Also da muss man schon sagen, ja und da würde ich jetzt auch nicht Extremitäten sagen, sondern würde sagen in Armen und Beinen oder Händen und Armen oder so.
Das würde ich schon ein bisschen präzisieren.
Gut, gut. Ja, so viel kann ich für heute Abend sagen.
Ich habe neulich schon gesagt, dass ich am Dienstag sicherlich nicht anbieten kann.
Da kann ich leider keine Anamnese machen.
Da bin ich tatsächlich um die Zeit auch noch unterwegs auf der Strecke.
Das fahre ich von hier weg.
Und ich versuche aber am Donnerstag anzubieten.
Das würde ich aber auch nach Ihrer Kollegin, die die ganzen Termine im Augenblick verwaltet, der würde ich noch schreiben.
Und ja, bei allen anderen sage ich für heute herzlichen Dank bei Ihnen.
Danke, dass Sie sich um die Patientin gekümmert haben.
Und bis zur Prüfung ist ja noch eine ganze, fast ein ganzer Monat hin.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns noch bei einem der nächsten Termine.
Vielleicht kann ich dann auch nochmal gucken.
Ich habe jetzt hier heute keinen Münchner Fall mit gehabt.
Aber wir können gucken, dass wir dann in der nächsten Woche vielleicht einen haben.
Gut, ja, für heute herzlichen Dank.
Vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen, fürs Zuhören.
Und dann sehen wir uns maximal in einer Woche.
Schönen Abend für Sie alle und tschüss, machen Sie es gut.
Ciao.